calvin harris spotted out with a  stunning new lady we fell in love  as the leaves turn brown check out the  32 year old producer DJ on Saturday  night in LA walking arm-in-arm with  brunette beauty a Issa Gonzalez a  Mexican actress and singer previously  linked to Cristiano Ronaldo and Liam  Hemsworth the pair certainly looked cozy  in their all-black ensembles as they  exited a party together and we could be  together me  Calvin split from his former flame  Taylor Swift in June after over a year  of dating ever since he seemingly  enjoyed the single life he's also been  linked to singer Tinashe I mean I really  we hang out he's really cool um but I'm  definitely single as for Taylor ET  confirmed on Tuesday her whirlwind  romance with Tom Hiddleston has ended  after just three months  and I'll write your name do you think  Calvin and ASA are a new couple or just  pals for now tell us your thoughts on  twitter at ET now